bloody emails
we've got uh live streaming has started
now so um
have you ever started the meeting yet
and just a warning live streaming okay
cool
I'm gonna come over here
honestly there's so many pages
and I think Chris is coming to the same
thing yeah
but well
we will have a go
between angels
okay welcome everybody to
infrastructure Services committee
meeting 7th of March
2023. just want to explain first
how it's going to run today because we
have an extraordinary council meeting
and we're going to do the public session
of infrastructure first then we're going
to move into public excluded I'm going
to adjourn the meeting immediately the
PE and we'll continue streaming and then
we'll do the extraordinary Council and
at the end of that or recommence the
public excluded of infrastructure
so apologies there are none we have
Pioneer on Zoom welcome Ponyo
thank you I have no Declarations of
Interest interests that have been
notified there is no public forum
and we'll start off with the minutes
from the
infrastructure meeting 7th February 2023
can I have someone please move the truth
correct thanks Trish second in Nigel
thank you I'll put that all those in
favor
against that is carried moved to the
minutes of the extraordinary obstructure
Services committee meeting 14 Feb 2023
can I have someone please move true and
correct
uh move Darren second Evelyn thank you
put the Motions on those in favor
against its carry that takes us on to
item five uh six which is the
encroachment and potential disposure
disposal of land here though welcome
thank you
good afternoon Mr chair councilors
um
so as part of a routine check on some
lens
we um discovered that there was some
encroachments for adjoining business
owners at House of land which forms part
of the old landfill site
um and following on notification to
those landowners about the encroachments
in Aquarius to whether or not they would
be interested in purchasing they have
come back and said they might be
interested in that process
um so the parcel of land for that that
is the
the whole parcel of land
sits in one title
and there are some restrictions around
um disposal
in terms of any of that land and that
there is a resource management act
restriction so that the land is
Amalgamated to a jointing land for the
purposes of making sure it does not
become land locked so it has to have
some sort of excess way
um and
um so what I've done also discovered as
part of that there was another parcel to
the north which is currently being
occupied by the New Zealand motor
Caravan Association in conjunction with
the parcel of State Street Reserve that
they also lease
um under the reserve management plan for
steadstret
so I have split the report into two to
deal them with them as the two different
Parcels of land
which I thought would be easier for
counselors and if we would like to take
it in the two separate parcels
Lot 2 which is the the North Parcel
which is the New Zealand motor Caravan
Association
inquiries with the Parks and Recreation
manager
have resulted in
um parks
um being open to investigating whether
or not this might be a parcel of land
that either would be disposed of to the
New Zealand motor Caravan of association
with an easement proposal across the
land
or amalgamating it to the stead Street
Reserve depending on how that looks
and there's been no
um approach to the association as yet
this is simply an investigation
processor at this time
um
there are uh
no changes to the land in terms of the
use of the land
um that would give them tenure for the
land if they were to purchase the land
or alternatively if we were to move it
into stead Street Reserve it would be
managed as a whole with one Caravan Park
under the reserve set in terms of the
allowances under there as well
in terms of the other parcel of land the
encroachments is fairly easy to see from
the photos how much encroachment has
happened
it's just happened over time
um
there are obvious contamination issues
but the majority of the contamination
issues that there are as a result of the
actual encroachment process not as the
use of the landfill site
previous testing has noted that the
landfill site did not go that far north
um and so this is kind of just outside
of their area
there is no continued monitoring along
this puzzle of land either of these two
passes have land in terms of
um and normal
um site monitoring for the landfill site
it's a little bit further over there are
however
some notifications under the district
plan in terms of
it is in a
um sea level rise area and
natural Hazard Zone
and any development on either of these
Parcels of land would be
processed through the district plan and
the resource consent processing
I don't there's anything further I can
add and I wonder if there's any
questions though I'm more than happy to
answer okay here's the before I open and
up to questions just to confirm
recommendation three we have up there
approve the method of disposal now yeah
would correlate with what you have as
preferred option yes and then both lot
two and three yes okay so I'm just
wondering do we need to
um have more detail in three we can
update point three with the preferred
option yeah as counter okay James right
I'm going to open up two questions
counselors
yeah there you nailed it
oh here we go Ellen just one quick
question
um
um have you approached the motor Caravan
Association and seen what they would
prefer not at this stage this
the um when I when I was doing the
report I noted that the two Parcels of
lean were tied together so there has
been no approach to them at this stage
um the initial approach will be to see
what might be the preferred option um
okay yeah that's good
we're also sorry can I just yeah
clarified we'll also have to confirm
whether or not
um having an easement over adjoining
land to a parcel of land will be
available under the
um the confines of the reserves
management
does that mean that the the
including it as a part of the reserve
might be the it may be the better easier
option yeah just a quick question about
um parcel two the long film parcel I
notice it goes behind a lot of
properties yes are you envisaging
breaking it up and giving a piece to
each that was offering a piece to each
that would be the point
well because I noticed that although it
sounded like one person had been
approached that there were lots of
businesses all of the businesses have
been approached they've all been
approached thank you that was my
miscarriage sorry for the most
clarification
right mister yeah just uh just to
declare a bit of an interest I'm in the
association but not involved with the
local branch so I just got some
questions about that parcel of land at
the moment the pieces in front of what's
available which is your read back is
where they currently occupy yes is there
any suggestion to them that we would
swap the land
so the piece of so when we swap the land
that's closer to the engineering firms
and they then gift us back the other
land which would fit better with the
with the reserve running around there
sorry I'm just not sure which parts of
land you're talking
about yep yeah change those two with the
red one so as opposed to selling it is
there an option if you wanted to look at
you said one of the options was to look
to uh
um putting the land back under
um parks and reserves the clear the
motor Caravan Association are occupying
both part of both the part that's
outlined in red and the joining States
Reserve as part of their so they've got
both Parcels now they're they're
releasing areas yes yeah
because one of the issues that they've
raised with me
is that the area that's adjoining the
part that runs down by the S3 is
problematic to them with uh what they
would refer to as Homes at night time
are beside we're the car park is yeah
it's dead straight yep uh yep down with
the old woofers a lot of people go down
there at night time so there's quite a
bit of disruption for the people that
are parking in that area parking up
overnight so that's to the west of where
they're camping their Association Park
is
um
and you're suggesting they move well I
don't know I mean if they didn't want to
buy would it be more preferential that
they take what you've got enclosed in
that red area at the moment as their
at their lease land or something they
might purchase and leave the rest of the
Landers going back into the park
so the the Restriction would still be
that that would be a potential
landlocked area if unless we Amalgamated
it to the State Street Reserve because
there's no
easement access easily allowable to that
space down to to the South
but isn't it a driveway running in
from
Bond Street
no I said that piece at 263 is not as
that's private land
so it's to the south of that and that's
private access way 263.
on the on the greater one that you've
got in the bigger picture yes
um is it I can't read what's got because
your drawing's gone over the top of it
but is that part of the that arching is
that part of the Estuary is that the S3
in there yes it is
so uh MP Liz Craig has been doing work
around that history for quite some time
possibly years around trying to stop
some of the leaching that comes out of
the old dump so that area you've got
there I guess is the old dump yeah so
the largest space is pretty much the old
Greenfield site plus the existing part
and 383 so what obligation will we have
if we attempted to sell that at some
stage we'll dispose of it
given that we know that it leeches into
the yesterday
I can't answer that question I'm sorry
there's an environmental question
um in terms of the Estuary I guess I
want to be clear that
um the closed landfill meets all of the
consent conditions that we currently
have
um I'm aware of the fact that you know
there there is a push for us to do more
in that space than we are working with
environment Southland
um on that but I just want to be clear
that there is nothing um currently
happening at the current closed landfill
that puts us in breach of our consent
um in terms though of we've discussed
previously where we would potentially
offer for sale a piece of land that has
contamination or in other instances
closed landfills on it it's around
making sure that we the other parties
are aware of that and they need to do
due diligence in that space
okay
right we've got time then Grant
um this is really an extension of
Evelyn's question I think
um in the case of Lord City then
encroached Lund there are obviously
several businesses
um I'm a writing thinking that all of
them would have to greet it acquire the
Landis encroached before we could do it
otherwise let's put it for five but it's
throughout the five agreed and there's a
little bit Stuck in the Middle there's
then nothing that we could do with it
technically yes that would be correct
however
if say only three of the
businesses wish to purchase the land
they may purchase other Parcels that
would be adjacent that would form a
longer piece of land so my question
remains is it all or nothing it is All
or Nothing right we can't have a land
dog
with respect to the
piece that's occupied by the
Caribbean Associated Caravans
so
what can it not be treated the same as
the
parcel 3 I think it is in the blue in
Seoul look to be sold to the business
and to the east of it it could be yeah
yeah we hadn't investigated that but
it was a lease to the campervan to the
motor Caravan Association on that so it
would be so subject to that lease if
that was the process
Evelyn
just as a point of clarification
how do the caravaners actually enter
onto that site do they do it down 263
no to the north just as a right-of-way
access
later on like just at the bottom of the
terminal just above two four five
I just thought it was my bed my
eyesight's not that good so it's a
follow-up to that then the part of this
land that they have has got trees on it
has it also got
um other infrastructure that enables
people to
um stay for several days or a week or
whatever
um you know like electrical points and
um those sorts of things or is it just
um what they call boondocking or
whatever where you're self-sufficient
they are self self-sufficient Caravans
in there
other side with no
trees to protect so that's a hard space
yes yes that would
okay we're just gonna slight dilemma
here raised by Grant is that of we've
got now got the options
um approved the approved method of
disposal but Grant has opened up another
for
uh the camping ground is that it could
be sold
okay so at the moment we're looking at
and merging the two is the approved
option
um
uh
test order do you want is still keen on
that idea yeah right or at least
inspirational expiration okay
so we're gonna have to alter a 3A
in the sense that we're going to need to
it's going to be
um investigate potential
sale
um
say a little plant of that land
as well how would you weird then
yeah
so we'll just get into the writing right
zoom into the businesses in front as
opposed to well it could yeah
um Grant's raised something that wasn't
yeah and noting that it would be subject
to lease yeah
of
okay right we're just being told a bit
of procedural stuff here uh that we're
going to need to get into moving some of
these so we'll start with uh receiving
the report uh can I have someone please
move that move Leslie second to the
airport and put the motion all in favor
hi thank you against
um and then we'll go to two determine
that the land is not required for the
purposes landfill
thank you and seconded again by Eveland
I've got that motion all right
it's carried right when we move down to
three so we're going to do these we're
going to do 3A
um can I have someone move that please
the way it is remove Trish seconded
rear
um Now Grant if you'd like to alter that
ask for an amendment yes please yeah
and the amendment would be
that we investigate the sale of the lot
on the inside whatever it is Mr Jacob we
just could we just add on to the
existing a or alternative yeah
investigate yeah the sale yeah which
will come back potential for sale yep
and that is I'll just check with the
Mover and secondary and said okay
yep
this is not an arena do we not need to
vote on the amendment please
and then if the amendment was in that
we will write up the amendment so that
everybody's clear on what it is and then
vote
yeah yeah that's why I asked if it was
okay
so we're just about there
so it was all passed now
[Music]
we just talk about it housework first
got my hand on the button
oregano
ES
yes are we going to discuss this again
if you've changed what we discussed oh
no no all we've done is added something
different so oh I don't agree with it
now though you see
yeah and I would like to talk about the
fact that it should be offered to those
that are there first just like the other
piece of people who use the other land
as a matter of you know courtesy I think
it'll be a very unpopular decision right
if they know that it's gone to the
market you know you go to the guys in
front who don't use it now but these
guys do
so just getting a ride here that uh
while we're waiting on this is that the
amalgamation was going to remain as
reserved land and then be used with the
lease for the Caravan people correct and
this new option is actually disposal of
the land uh to a private
or the existing tenant or the existing
tenant yeah okay but they don't they
only lease it currently so why would
they want to buy it no sorry yeah they
will there has been an approach to them
at this stage so they may
did I think we should need to approach
them first
so before we go offering it to anybody
else right so remember that this is
classified as Reserve Land
with this this
it would be classified as Reserve Land
if it were Amalgamated to the result
okay now that's fine so it is available
to them and what what Ellen's raising is
the fact that would uh the first driver
refusal go to the Tina
um the Caribbean people
so just as a matter of process chair
there was
a situation recently where Council
looked at divesting a parcel of land to
existing leaseholder
and that was challenged into the market
correct so we're now changing that
stance
no no no no no because we're actually
saying walks in the market the
discussion's been around
we'll just go to the um
Caravan Association or the motorhome
Association and offer to them what I'm
suggesting is we offer it to
the businesses in front of all other
parties
but also well we can do and quite
effective would be yeah
I think what we're saying is that it's
going to be open market that goes to the
open market and that the leasi the
Caravan people and the two people in
front up the open market right we
wouldn't give either of them preference
under our current practice
is it great
uh I need to can we just seek some
clarification from Heather
um would we be in a position to put that
parcel of land to the open market or
only to adjoining owners or the existing
leasehold I think it would only be
adjoining owners
um or the existing leasehold if the
tenant has easement access available to
them through the resource management act
process
because of the constrictions around the
way it sits on the title yeah
so uh 263 would also have rights because
they have an easement running down off
the individual Street and into that area
I guess I just like to be cautious on
this this is a very contentious area
about cities providing spaces for the
motorhome Association
um if you've been watching the news in
the last six to eight months several
councils have been taken to the high
court on their inability to do it from a
purely an economic perspective
campervans are by Nature reasoning
wealthy people
um they come into the city they do a lot
of good but the opposition to them
coming to the city is from the people
that own the current um
Parks we motorhome parks where you go
and you pay 50 60 a night so we get some
pushback from them but certainly want to
leave the drive but we can encourage
this Association so that's one issue and
the other issue is they still have some
issues around uh no sewage dump on site
as well
so that breaks that with me
the one that was down the road to the MP
MPD station is closed Maria
sorry Mr chair I'm so I'm listening to
me and Obi
um with that
sorry Heather can I ask my understanding
is for that loss of land that is
currently at least by
the New Zealand motor vehicle
um
so they would under that lease have the
right for first
no there are no first rights original
okay so the second thing to that is
there is no gray waste or no amenities
on that link that is correct yeah so
therefore what are you saying Mr Mayor
well I'm saying that's one of the issues
for the association
oh it is yeah yeah but I mean you've got
to think about when you disposal and
it's not always the highest price you
want to be gaining so if you think about
some of the works going on at the moment
through uh just transitions we've
probably got a meeting with Minister
wood shortly about the government coming
to the party and building some houses in
avocado now our share of that of that
project might be that we free up land
now you could argue should we free up
land where we might be able to go to the
marketplace and get a better dog for it
but there's a wider social need as well
than just selling land clearly for what
to the highest bidder as it were that's
a little bit like you know when you sell
a pass a land that was a play year for
children because you could better
dollars for them
um so there's other people higher price
with it because then with this one yeah
yeah but what I'm saying is that you
might get more money if you sell it to a
neighbor but then you lose the social
impact of that land as well so taking
that on board yeah
um what I'm looking at now is that you
looking at the map you've got
for a private for a sale you've got lots
2.5 249 and 263 have the ability to buy
that and not leave the land landlocked
or it goes to what the preferred option
was now
um the mayor raises the point about
social good
and that and now I think that should be
a decision for this committee that we'll
actually vote to whether we actually
accept that Amendment and do that allow
allow the
exploration of selling it okay I think
that this committee should
all right you'd like to speak
yeah I do actually I've sort of put in
support of a Villain at this stage
because we've had effects types
practices the reason why we went to
Market was the other lot was it was
commercial
I didn't see I don't see actually the
Caribbean is commercial
it's more of social good is is uh Mia
Clark had twigged out and um yeah so I I
saw and then I go back to the decision
that we made around the Layton Street
section in Bluff where they went to the
neighboring interest
party so and as they had the right to to
purchase so
so yeah I I think the care of impact
should be at least considered
um to have the Opera approach so well
the way it's all access at the moment if
we go for the preferred option it would
become part of the reserve lease land be
changed into that and then become a
lease so the Caravan Association
wouldn't be put in the position of
purchasing anything they would just have
a renegotiate the lease for perhaps a
larger piece of land
so it would still be the same lace it
just would be Recreation Reserve
Recreation Reserve okay so that's part
of the option to purchase
the other option was to purchase with
amusements yeah
you mean the the purchase the um
okay so there was the two options for
the original
um
recommendation now
um Michael I ask you now procedurally
wise
um I'd like this committee to actually
make a call on
determining whether it is going to offer
up the land to uh for sale to the
potentially three other lot owners or or
not do that and
progress with the preferred option of
keeping it for a caravan is as Reserve
plan eventually
can hear me
um thank you Mr chair so you've got at
the moment there is a motion that has
been proposed uh so and and amended so
at the moment for the amendment to go
through councilors Bond and Boyle as the
Mover and second is but that was the
other way around
um need to endorse
the motion that was proposed originally
that Amendment as proposed by councilor
Dermody and that can be put if they do
not endorse that then councilor Germany
will need to hit put that motion himself
to amend
um
so they say they can be voted as it is
with the endorsement of the Mover and
secondary
and if it's then lost then
the next motion could be put again to go
back to what had been originally
proposed by staff
um but you'll need a new mover and
secondary right okay like we are backing
the traffic because we have yeah you
know they have agreed but it's good that
we've gone through this because I think
it's very important so we're going to do
that yeah I'm happy to
end of selling the land no
yeah
okay Mr chair it's probably important to
clarify this for both 3A and b or
justice
so yeah so I'm now gonna if this gets
voted down we go back to the original
it's
okay so it's knobby just another another
curveball for you
um the association on many parts and
music new parts of New Zealand does
actually buy land in their own rights
yeah they lease initially but then they
use their reserves to buy land so how
will it be if we were to offer three
potentially adjoining parties the option
to buy and we're not offering them the
option to buy as well we
those three lots Plus
um the Caribbean station okay thank you
should I just seek some clarity checks
here we go
hey there
um
you could put something to the market
which we've said isn't practical in this
situation or you can negotiate directly
with one party
um I would have thought that we would
struggle to negotiate with two parties
at once we would need to have a
preferred party to approach to begin
with
well can we negotiate with both at the
same time
we start giving ourselves a little bit
into trouble if we're trying to
negotiate with more than one party at
the same time
it might hit
um
Mr Morris might be able to answer that a
little bit
how come we can't negotiate with more
than one party I would say it would
simply depend on what process is yeah
determined there is options where you
can multi-negotiate but um Aaron is
quite right it can get untidy quite
quickly but again it's it's but as I
read this this is investigate the
benefits of either sale or
amalgamation this isn't the sale or
amalgamation
suggest that there may be something to
just bear in mind this isn't the final
determination of which way you're going
so you're saying if we if we do approve
um
what's written there it's going to come
back with another recommendation to
councils after the exploring once the
investigation has been done yes and
we'll have a second bite at the Cherry
yes and we'll have some better
indications from either the neighbors or
the motor Caravan Association I guess to
the interest actually that sounds pretty
so I'm going to go Alex and Leslie
um I'd just like to point out one
programs you can do if they would mind
into that motion
the sale
or investigate the benefits of either
sale to adjoining property owned
property owners or the current leasee
because at the moment it doesn't
actually stipulate that nztuma is an
option is that okay well I'm happy with
that yeah that's good okay Leslie I
think something mine was the same point
but around the other way you need to put
investigate benefits of either sale to
the current leasi or
who are joining property owners subject
to the lease or it doesn't make sense
okay you like the character first
you say you currently currently see if
we're going to say investigate the
benefits of I either sail to the current
leases got to go first so because this
next part is saying or to adjoining
adjoining property owners subject to the
least good point okay we got that yeah
we're going to get Mr Lee yeah
[Music]
when we talked about
um having multiple people that will be
approached it's not unheard of to
actually seek multiple offers on Parcels
of land
no your career that is correct but at
this stage we're still our only on the
investigation process and it's the
particular that comes back and just to
just to fill in time a little bit more
um would would we have this back by the
next
um what time period would you like um we
can bring this back to the next
infrastructure and we will have some
indication by then
okay Rio you still wanting to say
something okay right Evelyn Mr Tim when
are we going to talk about the public
part yeah well the public good part will
come back and the options so we'll be
looking at we won't have um monetary
numbers would we we need to bring it
back next meeting I'm not sure not sure
okay but but rest assured that this is
not a done deal it's exploration and
it's coming back again and no sale will
go ahead
correct without that is very much yes
yeah
I think you by proceeding with the
offering to to everybody before you talk
to the current tenant is sending a very
very very bad signal to to anybody else
that is even leases any any Council lamp
which I'm sure there are others which
means that nobody is safe nobody's
nobody nobody's secure and and at least
of any Council land if you offer it to
the market if you're if you're doing
business here which is what they are
doing if you're doing business there
then you get a consultative to your
neighbor for instance
um who might offer you twenty thousand
dollars more would you say suddenly your
business is defunct I mean I think
you're seeing a very very bad signal I
would just like to see them approach
first that's fine
okay Grant well so the the least should
determine that the leap the lease should
determine what happens in the event of a
sale and at least should determine
whether it's offered to the existing
releasey first yeah or it goes excuse me
go straight to Market so our leases need
to be reviewed unfortunately this little
piece of land is not being least it's
discovered oh it is yeah there's actual
there's a lease so the lease lease is on
the this parcel and the adjacent that
the lease goes over the adjacent Steel
Street Reserve as well my ass the term
of the lease
um so I've got the term of the list
there um so it's a five-year lease which
is due for renewal at 2025 with it's got
three rights of renewal on there for
five years so total terms three rights
of renewal
right you have opened up another
question here I think you're sitting
here
um we've got this sorry I thought this
land was just discovered that it was um
not part of
it's not part of the State Street
Reserve but they were releasing it even
though I'm sorry yeah right okay so it
was wingly so
um what we're asking Alan's asking is
that um would it be right that
Council asses the existing lead CEO of
that land to just to get the first
would that be right
it depends I think it's Council of
Germany indicator depends entirely on
what is in there least from a legal
point of view if there at least requires
it then that is the right thing to do
the question for this council is whether
morally it is a quick um the process you
wish to follow whether you feel that you
should consult with the existing
leaseholders before you proceed anywhere
else that is a better it's not a legal
issue unless it's in the lease
with you at all
yeah
and Mr chair would that not be
commercially sensitive that part of the
lease
that you want to open up or it's all
pretty sensitive are these leases are
public or are they done privately like
on reserved land
I would tend to agree that we're
starting to step into commercials yeah
okay so look look I'm actually going to
adjourn this we've got to a point I am
because we actually need to find out as
Peter Gray's the rights of the camping
people and we need to for the public
good we need to make sure we do that
right you can get that right first
and that if there is something in the
lease and everything that we're going
ahead agreeing to put this on trade me
um I don't yeah can we not stipulate
excuse me chair I think we're going to
have a we're going to end up with
uh 3A is going to be 24 paragraphs and
and I think it's just I don't know I I
think we're better off adjourning it and
bringing back this is not critical
time-wise no no okay so in the
you're making a good decision I would
sooner adjourn this put it on the shelf
and we come back with that that's a
critical part I see everyone's we've all
danced around it and I think we get that
sort of first
and uh and then move so sorry about that
okay sorry can I just
see something I mean for me I suspect
this loans must have been 10 bulb right
so yeah it's for me the critical
question is the public good one that
everyone's raised and when we look at
public good it's not only a matter of
you know the the rates of the lessee
which I think is actually what you said
I know you haven't meant it but that's
what you said it's a broader question
about the public good that I would like
to understand what's up being useful at
the moment
um who's staying there
um what would be the implication of
toughen them out and that to me is going
to be more important actually than the
10 bulb we made myself yeah the timber
so Leslie
thanks Mr chair I was just going to say
to avoid adjournment you could just add
to option two at the beginning subject
to the tombs of the current lease comma
and then the risk reads
completely subject to the terms of the
current lease I think I think that could
be okay if the characters only
investigating yes investigating subject
to the terms of the current police
seems to be what people want to have
what I did
so we will get a report back obviously
that are going to let us know the
current lease
um and then from there we will have the
option of the public good thing but we
still won't have an indication of value
of that how much 10 voltage just to
finish us all off now Mr chair um the
lease may have a clause on it that
precipitates us even discussing this
because they have the option yep so
that's the thing so there's no point
even discussing the Clause until we know
it's about the lease
so
that's point two
so I think that's thank you Leslie so
Nobby it's just as a final reflection
here look the current leases
have indicated that the campervan
associations got up till 2040.
I think to be jumping in early
um but without any warning to them and
just throwing some investigation stuff
in there I don't see
um look there's interests from third
parties to develop yes stead Street
Wharf into a cafe
that's commercially sensitive but
sitting right on a a track that we've
developed that goes to Bluff as well I
mean
why wouldn't you be very careful around
this we want them to be in that area
yeah
yeah so there we go
I thought we had no questions and then
we've gone to
four thousand so we're just about there
something
subject terms of the current lease to
just confirm with councilor sopa that is
in the right spot I was
put it right at the beginning so it's
the food the subject to the terms the
current lease is the first and then
investigate yeah and then a comma and
then investigate the benefits of either
sailed and the current BC or to the
adjoining property owners yes thank you
that will need to be endorsed by again
yes
Ria are you feel like endorsing you're
so doing Mr chair and I'm I'm really
mindful when I when I bring this um
um to the fact that
considering what we've been presented
with today I wonder if it would have
been more helpful if there had been some
more options presented and it's no
reflection or any on anyone in this room
in order to make us come to a
be the decision-making process with
public good included in that so
um I respect that you want to adjourn
and come back to it all these things
come up with another
[Music]
um
pass way through
um but I do wonder if they're
yeah head there have been some better
options knowing about the lease and
things like that that could have
happened we strike these as curables all
the way so I think this is just a
learning option that that um you know
next time we have
something like this yeah
yeah but this has been this has been fun
[Laughter]
I agree
Okay so we've passed one and two
um can I we've moved and seconded three
a I'm going to put the motion the way it
sits there now all those in favor all
right
against uh
okay
um that against I've got that you want
that I recorded that yeah you recorded
that I'm against as well okay would you
like that recorded
okay that three eight is carried uh that
moves now to Three B which is lot three
move that way
thank you Leslie seconded Evelyn we'll
put the motion all those in favor
against
carried
right
thank you
right because of that I'm actually going
to cancel item seven
even though actually it's item seven has
been withdrawn
that has been withdrawn because there's
some slight uh complications about uh
Russell will talk to that
thank you Russell good afternoon Mr
chair councilors and Mr Mayor um what
we've done is we've continued to have a
look at um our process for this changes
to the internet speed management
the change to the National Speed
register is something that's really
really new and we feel that at this
stage we wish to withdraw this paper and
represent it once we've actually ironed
out some of those
um some minor issues
um
we think it's better to get the process
absolutely right given the nature of the
speed limit so that's the reason behind
it okay excellent thanks guys that's
done we'll see you that would be how
many coming back when okay with this one
next Bank oh sorry next next meeting
um we hope to have it back in April but
it may well be May depending on if we
can get the solutions from nationally as
well no you did right we've got to get
these things right thank you thank you
okay it moves us on to item eight which
is the audible announcements on the
public transport you remember the last
meeting uh Carolyn Weston submitted
um in a public forum about the the need
for this and uh we see here that um
this particular contract is 13 months
away from being re-tended and Russell
isn't reading this that it'll be one of
the requirements is that right
um I think it needs to be one of the
considerations as we get a new contract
I guess those those features will be all
features that are are offered
to recognize that providing this these
types of equipment on the bus are
important to that sector certainly
recognize that but we also note that the
drivers are really more than happy to
actually have a conversation with with
users and and get that information in
that interim period I think we want to
make sure we can turn into look for a
good solution that can be independent of
the physical bus Which is the thing that
we trouble so if if we change buses we
have to change all the equipment so
we're really looking for something
that's a bit more technologically savvy
um and interesting since
um Carolyn made a presentation we've had
contact with two further companies who
are interested to talk about what we're
doing and what they're doing in other
places around the country so we are
continuing to look for a solution it's
not that we just want to stop we want to
find something that actually gives a
solution that we can use a in the buses
or elsewhere because I think if we can
find that there'll be many other places
around the country will want to have
something similar to us as well
okay right uh questions on this Tom
could ask it what puts a problem with a
microphone and a driver
what's the problem with that I mean I
know it's very very low Tech but
presumably this is a way of advising
people when they've reached a stop or
Mr chair I think one of the things with
that would be is we'd want the drivers
to be concentrating on their driving day
um I've seen some of the places they
drive the buses and they're quite quite
a challenge and and keeping it up they
do drive all the routes so knowing
exactly which the stoppers would be
um
I think the drivers know it know it
um the people who are using the buses
they regularly use them so the people
with in the disability sector that want
to get off at a specific location
typically I being serviced and dropped
off at right at the place even at um I
think if there's any user that regularly
gets off will find a convenient place
close to where they want to get off at
the moment so except accept the offer
the opportunity to actually say well the
driver could announce it but I think
that might be something we wouldn't want
the driver to actually try to do as well
as driving
as a regular Buster user
um I wondered about the likes of
how friendly to things like Google Maps
it might be you know like when you set
your
route to go
is that a conversation we're having
because they actually tell you when when
they're going to turn and
how far away the next corner is and all
that sort of thing is it worth talking
to organizations like that or I guess as
a cost to that
that's where our direction is headed to
see whether we can get a reason me
um
accessible to the market type solution
that's available and I think something
around the Google solution may be a
backdrop for it but it really wants to
be customizable to invercargill when I
think the thing we want to do is to be
able to add in specific stops if we
create new stops so we can do that so it
needs to be a little bit customizable
but certainly a gap in the market in
terms of that technology at the moment
physically
thanks Mr chair
um Russell I know how good air drivers
are and I know it's very much
appreciated but can we just get an
assurance that
as part of this because it is going to
be another at least 13 to 16 months
probably
um will the blind Foundation be
officially informed that
drivers can be asked and that way I know
there's a lot of regular users but
there's also the the sectors also got a
number of occasional users
certainly we have a number of
opportunities to meet with them and have
conversations about the sorts of things
we're doing with the passenger transport
and Total Mobility and certainly can we
can continue to raise with them great
thank you okay Trish
would it be possible in the process of
what you're looking for a new initiative
to use on the buses that you do a review
at the end of the period and see whether
you actually need them then if the
drivers are going to be able to manage
the people as you suggested that may
well be we don't need it
I recognize that could be an opportunity
I think one of the things that we've
heard from the sector is that they like
the independence and if we could offer
that as a an ideal solution with a use
of Technology wisely um it could also be
that it could actually help give them
directions to other locations around the
city so it wouldn't necessarily have to
be necessarily confined to a bus that
seems to be relatively unusual that we
can't use some of our technology to help
them in a wider sense
further questions comments okay we have
two recommendations in front of us on
the on the screen can I please have
someone move rear seconded Evelyn and
we'll put those two recommendations
those in favor
against that is Carrie thank you that
moves us on to the parking control bylaw
the movement
thanks Mr chairman and I guess there's a
slight um is for an in
um in that I have an inconsistent so
under the Strategic consistency I'd like
to actually just alert counselors to a
um mistaken there that it says it's
inconsistent with good governance it
should be saying it is consistent with
good governance so I apologize for that
for that mistake in that context
this is I guess one of the regular
things that we need to bring
to use for minor amendments to our
bylaws so in this case it's a parking
the parking control so this is where we
have relatively minor changes to the
regulatory structure of the parking and
we need to keep what's physically out
there in the real world aligned to what
our regulatory Maps which we include on
the bylaw so we've brought a number I
think um nine relatively minor changes
that we are seeking councils
um
approval for okay we're not selling any
of these but
no we're not we're going to open up
questions questions or comments please
committee no okay on that case without
silence we have the two recommendations
uh
up there will receive the report
the amendment and then in accordance
with such and such
um Patricia you want to move that yes
yes seconded Leslie put their emotional
loads in favor
aye against that is carried and that
takes assignment of the final
report activities report and
Aaron
thank you chair
two two key points that I'd like to
speak to today with regard to the
activity report
um one is just to draw that draw
attention to the work that's happening
at the Clifton plant with regard to the
removal of biosolid from the site
and the second one is just a verbal
update with regard to
the water restrictions that we currently
have in place I didn't want to put a a
written update as at the time that the
report went through things are very
different and moving in that space But
what I would update council is that
currently the flow levels in the oriti
river are sitting in the High Falls
with the rain that we have had we did
see a blip where we moved up towards
that 15 qmix space but very quickly
again without sustained rain those
levels continue to drop down obviously
the the sort of further we get out of
the summer period the less our risk of
having to bring in more rigorous
restrictions becomes but we are not
outside of the risk period where further
restrictions may be necessary we're just
tracking that on a weekly basis
thank you uh questions or comments on
the activities report
okay so we have
um two recommendations uh three-part
just yes sorry I was elsewhere in the
agenda um
the bluff Hill uh
event that we had this year I understand
it was an accident or accident plural do
we get any information about
um what happened there and whether
there's any Improvement in the um
safety structure around that for next
year's event
I don't believe that we've had any
feedback have we Russell
not that I'm aware of
it's terrible believe it the incident
that occurred as part of their event so
the event itself will have a debrief and
we could seek some clarification from
them of uh
of the direction for future years to
each year they wish to use their hill
and you'll recall that you get a request
to a temporarily stop the road so it
wouldn't be unfair to understand what
safety measures are to protect your
interests thank you
sure
um just along that same line I know
great sales report that was online
acknowledge what amazing out for
tomorrow if it was and how successful it
was and didn't once even give any
Credence to the people who've been
injured
and I think that was um I mean that's
not a piece of the work but it is part
of what we do
I don't know whether we tell them
I believe they should have given even
mentioned you know I hope the families
are right or something and it doesn't
even figure in their report
from the the report was from there from
Great South great sir on on the event
right okay
I think we could Endeavor to take a note
and provide that feedback yes and so
thank you sounds great South is at CCR
of this Council yeah
yeah
thank you any other questions or
comments thanks Tom let me ask um
there's a problem for Russell too
what sort of feedback we are getting on
the speed limits the replied a couple of
months ago are you are you still getting
almost none which is probably good are
you getting you know
people coming with fire Brands and
burning Crossings to your door
also call on my colleague Leslie she
gets to answer most of them my
recollection is that we have a
a number of inquiries but most people
start are starting to understand where
we're heading with with with this um
these changes
but we're not necessarily seeing huge
opposition so far on any of them and
they're well better down as I would see
it and I think we've been pretty much
successful and um
there's been a number of instances and
other I guess forums where we've been
able to stand and say well we've
actually made a giant leap forward
whereas other councils are having
a quite different debate about speed in
there and their community
thank you Evelyn
what
um councilor Campbell said I want to ask
about the um movable
speed indicators though
um the electronic ones that flash and
say you are doing
whether there's some
possibility
of that going to some of the more
problematic
um
stretches of road like Martin Street
where people are speeding towards the
traffic lights still
um
just to give people an indication
because I don't think some drivers are
aware of exactly how fast they're going
when they're approaching those corners
and Monsieur those signs are movable we
just need to reinstall a socket and
physically uplift them take them there
they run off solar panels so that's how
they've been generated
some some of the newer ones do have some
devices that actually record some of
those speeds so we can actually get a
clearer picture of what is actually
happening
because often the perception of what
people we see when we actually look at
the numbers that's not off on the
it's quite variable so if we've got some
locations I'm happily to receive some of
those and we can look at locations for
suitable areas to move them interesting
enough the signs were put in the places
they were because they were the
problematic areas
at that time
thank you
Russell my question would be obviously
the laws of physics say with their
reaction there's an equal and opposite
reaction you know why when you create
these speed limits have you found that
people's
habits have changed and then they now
try and take a quicker
shorter or you know as as it put
pressure on other streets
reasons we brought the report about the
speed limit was Macquarie Street was one
of these areas where a non-intendent
consequence was that people are using
that road instead of using their Network
the way we intended right so um yes
introsive has had some areas but very
little as far as we're aware I okay so
Macquarie street is that's one of the
reasons
who typically look for what they
perceive as the um
albeit the easiest slash fastest route
and I guess that's not always the route
that we wish as a network operator to
actually have people so
that's the mix because what we've also
found is that everybody wants people to
go slow past their house
right Maria were you wanting to speak oh
no I don't know Mr chair I was just
gonna say could you stop hooning around
there okay
right we've got two recommendations two
a b c and d plus to receive the report
can I have someone move that please Tom
and seconded rear and put those
recommendations all those in favor hi
against that is carried
that is the end of public session now
can I have someone please move that
we're going to thank you grant and to PE
second dead Tom
um emotion all those in favor
we are in public excluded I am now